to calculate the standard deviation we
can use this equation Sigma is the
standard deviation n is the number of
persons x i is the size of each person
and X bar is the mean value of all
persons so the standard deviation is the
root of the sum of square deviations
divided by the number of values so each
individual person has some deviation
from the mean but on average the people
deviate 11.5 centimeters from the mean
which is the standard deviation now you
might notice one thing I always talk
about the average deviation from the
mean in the case of the standard
deviation it is not the arithmetic mean
which is used but the quadratic mean so
far is good but now there's one more
thing to consider